[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
but i remember dude i would start should
i remember going on camping trips and we
the day we would leave i'd be like you
know jay leno died nobody like no
[ __ ] way
it would be out in the woods for a week
and everybody would think that jay leno
died
and i knew he didn't do it and we would
have these [ __ ] things and we'd talk
stay up at night talking about
you know the tonight show and [ __ ] like
that then they get back and like he
wasn't dead
and i remember he'll be like that's
psychotic to do that remember when chuck
ledell was the king of the world
yeah but one day eddie bravo's having
dinner with eddie with
with dana white and you know how eddie
brown was a big fidel castro fan
is he really yeah dude fidel came and
spoke to me one time i went to cuba once
did he really yeah
when [ __ ] fidel died i call him up
and i go eddie do you know fidel died
he thought i said liddell he looks at
dana white he goes chuck ledell's dead
i'll call you back
ever since i've been with him i just get
unlocked i've never had
i never had skin issues and now i get
styes if i look at a hot tub
trust me
his ear is swollen that's why i sleep on
my stomach i was
trying to sleep on your stomach i do
like a [ __ ] dead animal
yeah i'm like armadillo yeah or on my
side i'm or mostly i either my stomach
or my size
do your arms touch the ground yeah of
course how do you even do
that you have no idea
dog right who sleeps on your stomach
face down
no yeah oh face to the side i have
pillows yeah oh face to the side
jesus christ i thought you slept
dude you're a [ __ ] unreal league i
figured what we were talking about they
should have dolls they should have the
least cyan dolls bro
they're indestructible dude i had a car
that blew up in new york
yeah i took a loan on that car like i
took a loan out on that [ __ ] car when
i was a kid
i had to call for 10 days yeah and it
lit on fire and all
of those was getting they bought coke no
winter the electrical circuitry went oh
dude and i left it there the next two
three days later i went back in the car
was gone it was just a wish boat
and dog i took a bank loan out of there
like a two thousand dollar bank loan
co-signed
i didn't give a [ __ ] and even the
co-signer never said nothing to me about
it i'm like damn
what is he gonna hate on me i forgot all
about it
like are you serious you're a must point
too so yeah yeah dude i used to live my
mom used to live out off of uh golf
links off like on the east pantana like
way out there on the east side
tucson arizona yeah because you got a
kid that lives in tucson really oh
really
call he lives in got sam it's not it's
fox isn't his name is it
no no no no no no because they had a guy
fox i used to work for could [ __ ]
kidnap that dude but he was also kind of
cool too
tucson used to have one of the craziest
comedy rooms of all time it's called
bugsies
yeah on tuesday nights you gotta give
him a bug to get in uh-uh
yeah a real bug a bug used to book the
room
if you showed up with a bug they'll let
you in for free oh my god the guy that
ran the place had to weigh 900 pounds
yeah like eight next but he had cocaine
that would make you go [ __ ] blind
that was all cortisol in his neck from
doing coke
it was hilarious he had the best coke in
the world i love that it was 150
for the night and there was three comics
we all got paid the same
guess who i remember going down there
with like my second or third time and he
got the virginized
mencia fluffy really that's how young
gabriel was
wow we took him down there one time they
came back he was paying i was like man i
got my dick sucked he was like 18
hanging out with uncle joey's [ __ ] dude
you feel better five more what's the
difference right now that you feel
yeah i mean i feel like no refund no
sleeping pills
no no no nothing just straight up water
maybe somehow
i'll hit up a cialis five milligram you
know if i'm trying to party a little you
know
i'm trying to treat a lady to an evening
or something but uh
you know i'll drop nine dollars on that
i got a dude that'll you know
when does that start happening what the
seattle's five milligrams oh i throw
that just because look dude you know
what i'm saying like
you know i can be michael jordan but if
i could have scottie pippen next to me
but i'll do it you know
like there's no point not having him in
the ring with you you know
you know you don't shut you you know you
got to bring a
you got to bring a knife to a bun fight
you know what i'm saying yeah it's so
petrified to eat one of those things
oh you gotta throw dude i'll tell you
i'll put one of those in my butt dude
they go
quick to your cocktail dude what is this
[ __ ] in the last week we've had somebody
who put
what's she putting her [ __ ] coke
extra tea
oh yeah boof and these kids are boofing
when they blow cocaine in each other's
butts
i read about that that's a colorada
thing what do they do
they put cocaine in the end of a straw
and then they put the other
they put the other end into somebody's
butt and then they blow it in there
i did that 25 [ __ ] years ago i
invented that one
with a dollar bill your booth with a
dollar bill
you get the hepatitis c attached to the
dollar bill and [ __ ]
if i don't have hepatitis c i ain't got
nothing man bro
from all those [ __ ] dollar bills and
snorting that [ __ ]
hysterical oh my god what the [ __ ]
there's another star to balance you out
yeah you gotta [ __ ] balance out your
ph
you need some [ __ ] uh a little bit of
horchata bro you need to [ __ ]
hit up the mexican milkmaid bro get it a
spray in your mouth a little [ __ ] lee
get your back you got a baby bird you
little get your back on the branch
get your back on the embrace is [ __ ]
up
for you people are not watching this
dude uh i remember one time we
uh this uh
um [ __ ] uh you got me out to death for
you i'm gonna be the dead
i'm in munich
[Laughter]
you know my thing now sometimes if i get
lonely by myself and stuff i'm by myself
i'll end up watching pornography or
something you know and i'll shut the
blinds and [ __ ] cuz i ain't jerking off
with the [ __ ]
blinds open you know like some kind of
you know like a [ __ ] camp counselor
you know what i'm saying so i closed
shop up
let me do some [ __ ] call a shout out
to you and we'll wrap this up yeah there
we go i think that's the idea
he's feeling [ __ ] up now don't start
let him get electrocuted it's all right
we need somebody to get electrocuted on
this show
i got electrocuted when i was younger
man actually you don't save me bro
a brother save me man and i don't know
if you're out there would you stop
already
you got elected
these was coming a day early to the fair
to test the rides we didn't know
another time i went
to a movie i went to see ac dc
with a friend of mine kurt dilorenzo god
bless his soul
and we got we did coke that night and
boo
like blackberry brandy but me and him
were tight
and one night he pulled the leona me him
and his kid louis caslito went to a
movie
i can't remember what movie it was but
on the way home
we were on [ __ ] fire yeah
like the acid was beaming we were
tripping we were seeing [ __ ] that's
crazy bro
and i think it was
louis castellino kept saying guys
i keep hearing sirens and there were
sirens
but i kept telling them i wanted no
sirens
and the other dude played the wrong way
he's like i don't hear them
we kept walking there must have been a
fire somewhere
there's sirens everywhere this guy's
like what i wonder what's going on
why are there sirens and we're like we
don't hit no [ __ ] sirens knock it off
and it had just rained like the movie
theater rain like
it rained a ton and there was a pothole
with water on it
now we're [ __ ] with him for at least
15 minutes
about the [ __ ] sirens he's hitting
his ears and [ __ ]
he's like i gotta make it stop i gotta
make it go away
we're [ __ ] howling me and kurt and
there's a pothole filled with water
and i'll never forget he bent over and
took the water
and started coming on his face
that's god splashing the water on his
face
and he kept saying i still hear the
sirens and we're like listen
knock it off there's no [ __ ] sirens
and after about another block again
he just took off and ran oh yeah
the next day we saw him he's like that
was [ __ ] up last night
because i went home i came here in
silence
oh my god
that is the best when you take somebody
down well he knelt down on kennedy
boulevard dog and splashed
water on his face from the bottle
i nearly fight it was right across from
fairview [ __ ] diner
me and joy and this was a little hill so
all the water ran into that pothole
oh nice there was a couple inches of
water when he bet the street was still
away
from dog when he bent over and splashed
water on his face
that was a killer right there was a
spare bedroom or what was it we had a
full apartment we had a full apartment
it was her personal bedroom though
yes okay see that's disgusting yeah all
that people bang in my bed and come on
my headboard and [ __ ]
people spraying out oh yeah we
disrespected we went to we
we disrespected that let me tell you
something you just come on the headboard
and rub it in like [ __ ]
lemon what's that joey what's that [ __ ]
you polished wood with us
uh old english they come back they got
to sleep with that old dna of diaz
lurking over your head and [ __ ] yeah i
think cold english
that's a liquor and it has a malt liquor
that's why we left it which i just
i didn't it was gonna rain there was
gonna be fireworks so we were gonna stay
if there was gonna be fireworks but then
it was raining and it was just like
this person's it was like her college
apartment kind of
it was like everything that was like
someone else went to ikea
and they stayed at a dorm at [ __ ]
pretty much i'll stay
long beach it was not good you know i
knew dude i mean
you know i grew up around some [ __ ]
real crazy poor white people
you know the dude know all if they had a
dude in our town no arms
used to [ __ ] fight everybody you know
that dude you know i'm saying he'd get
you in that lurch he would
catch you with his between his chin and
his chest he would [ __ ] snack you
like a snake
we were talking about this dude his boy
gert was his name
and he would just get you like that bruh
and he'd choke you down
he had no no arms at all and he'd fight
anybody dude
and he would choke you he would show if
you went to punch him how would he block
oh bro he spin out of it he'd spin he
duck he dodged
the dude had [ __ ] i mean he just and
will he catch your hand with his neck
huh would he catch oh he would just
lurch at you and bro the thing is here
was it oh
you know what if he hits you with that
shoulder you're going down
yeah part of it but the big move was
that choke he would get he would
catch you like this where would he catch
you in your neck
he would catch you neck to neck
that's [ __ ] crazy once he got you
neck to neck gert you but
this whole family the whole family was
[ __ ] he could choke you out psychos
bro
brother had sharpened half of his teeth
on one side of his mouth dude these
people would [ __ ] you up
one of the kids was in a wheelchair or
just they never taught him to walk i
think i don't even think he was crippled
they just never taught him to walk
and so the other brother would carry him
on his back everywhere like a backpack
dude
and didn't even give a [ __ ] these people
are
are away from society an entire family
no shirts bruh
whole family zero shots nobody those
people don't wear shirts
[Music]
know